There's no reason that the scientific lens
has to be limited to interpretations or understandings
so they're simply material, only that which we can touch,
which we can point to.
(bright music)
Right now we're not studying spirituality.
We've been educated out of our awakened awareness.
We've been educated out of our spiritual awareness.
(upbeat music)
What if I told you that all humans,
all of us are equipped with this innate capacity
for spirituality.
Maybe you can wrap your head around that.
But here's the kicker.
Now hard science, I'm talking about neuroscience
actually proves that cultivating spirituality,
what today's guest calls the awakened brain,
leads to things like greater grit,
greater optimism, greater resilience.
And conversely insulates us against things like addiction,
trauma and depression.
We're here today to explore this fascinating and emergent
science of spirituality is a woman who helped pioneer it,
Dr. Lisa Miller.
Lisa is a professor of psychology and education
at Teachers College, Columbia University.
And is the founder and director
of the Spirituality Mind Body Institute,
which is the very first Ivy League graduate program
and research Institute in spirituality and psychology.
Lisa is widely published in leading academic journals.
Her first book, The Spiritual Child,
was a New York times bestseller
and her latest and the focus of today's discussion
is entitled The Awakened Brain.
I think you'll find our discourse fascinating.
It's just full of counterintuitive findings
and practical advice on the many concrete ways
to access your innate spirituality
and how spiritual practice can be actually deployed
to enhance joy, personal fulfillment,
and ultimately contribution to the greater wellbeing of all.
If you enjoy the content we labor here to create weekly,
it would mean a lot if you could subscribe to the channel,
if you haven't already.
And with that, please enjoy my conversation
with Dr. Lisa Miller.
Lisa, nice to meet you thank you for doing this.
(indistinct).
Excited to talk to you about my favorite subjects,
science and spirituality,
and the interesting inextricable link between them.
You've had a fascinating career
looking at this in depth for a long time
and we're gonna unearth all of it.
Fantastic.
I think the first thing we should probably do,
and I'm reluctant to even ask this question
because I'm sure it's the first question
that everybody asks you,
but I feel like we need to get it out of the way.
In terms of evaluating the sort of scientific
based benefits of cultivating a spiritual life.
We should probably define what you mean by spiritual?
Great, so thank you.
As you are well aware,
scientists do not define spirituality all told
but we can use the lens of science
to identify threads of lived human spiritual life
that have enormous impact on the rest of our lives,
our health, our wellness, our performance,
our ability to connect and love.
And the two threads within lived human spirituality
where I focus in The Awakened Brain,
are the two areas where the lines share of science says,
our lives are entirely different.
These two threads of live spirituality
are entirely game changing.
When it comes to our possibility and our realization
and they are one, the seat of transcendent awareness.
Which is to say our innate hardwired capacity
to see into the deeper nature of life
where we see that we are loved, held,
guided and never alone.
There's a capacity hardwired on us to see
a transcendent relationship with life.
That is the first of the two.
And the second is that that might be shared with one another
so that we can show up and be part of that symphony of life
where we're loved, guided, held and never alone.
Because we treat each other that way.
And how do you parse the differences
between spirituality kind of casting this broad umbrella
versus religion?
Spirituality and religion are two different things.
For two-thirds of people in the United States,
they go closely hand in hand.
So two-thirds of people in the U S will say,
"I am spiritual and I am religious."
My deep spirituality by which usually is meant
this thread of lived spirituality identified
in The Awakened Brain.
My state of transcendent awareness,
my capacity to be in a deep dynamic relationship
with the deeper presence for spirit in life
that is held in my faith tradition,
the prayers, the ceremonies, my community, the rituals.
30% of millennials and fewer with each older generation say,
"I am spiritual but I'm not religious."
For me I experienced spirituality in nature, art, my family.
So religion is through the lens of science
has been shown to be transmitted entirely environmentally.
It is a gift of our ancestors, it is shared by community.
But spirituality as I'm discussing it in The Awakened Brain,
our innate capacity for transcendent awareness
and that might be shared.
That is hardwired.
It is not merely a gift of our environment.
So spirituality is innate and the environment alone
transmits religion.
Sure, innate and also heritable.
Which is something you'll get into,
which is super interesting.
But before we even do that I suspect that...
And you talk about this in the book.
That it is a challenge for many and obviously some
within your profession to kind of reconcile
science and spirituality.
It presents this conundrum, this conflict.
Spirituality being something that is
considered outside of science
that is something anecdotal and observational.
So walk me through the process of trying to drill down
on how you actually study,
not just the impact of a spiritual life
on one's mental health but just identifying it
in a situation where it can be calibrated
to produce results that are reliable
and compelling enough to draw conclusions from.
Okay, so Rich, many people will say,
"Indeed, I am not spiritual.
I am very scientific."
And very often, certainly there was a huge ice age
around spirituality in the scientific community
in the 20th century.
It's starting to thaw a bit now.
But for most of the 20th century and still many people...
The bad gift that science as a profession
gave our larger society was a false split
between spirituality and science.
And that is indeed a very false split.
It turns out that science is a method, it's a lens.
Whether you're talking about genotyping or MRI studies
or long-term clinical course studies,
science is a form of observance.
And we can point that lens at just about any question.
And the host of questions are broad.
We can ask questions that are compelling and new,
or we can repeat the same questions
we've asked a hundred times before.
The questions we ask
live within the imagination of the scientist.
So the limitations that science faced on turning our lens
to ask questions of spirituality in the human life
were limitations of the culture, the climate,
the vogue in which scientists were immersed.
They were not limitations of the scientific method.
Now with the shift in culture came a shift
really the thaw in the ice age
of the imagination of the scientist.
And as culture in some ways
academia is the last to the party.
Our culture became much more spiritually aware
before academia got on board.
And as the group of scientists who were early
in this transformative process being amongst those labs
that really brought the lens of science to spirituality
in the human life.
Still to this day I can say there's a number of scientists
who've yet to separate the difference
between the scientific method and the vogue,
tastes and appetites and the culture
around academic science.
Which are actually sort of implicitly latently
secular material.
There's no reason that the scientific lens has to be limited
to interpretations or understandings that are simply...
I don't mean materialistic,
although that can come with material
but material only that which we can touch,
which we can point to.
I literally have friends who are scientists
who say that because you've shown the neural correlates
of spirituality and the brain
we now know spirituality is real.
That is a limitation in the culture of scientists,
not in our method.
Yeah, that's wild.
Do you think that this innate proclivity
for cultivating spiritual awareness
to developing the awakened mind as you call it,
is something that is specific to humans?
Does it exist across other areas of the animal
phenotypes out there or is this a human thing
that is particular to our species in the way that
bees know how to make a hive
or spiders know how to spin a web?
Like something that's...
Or birds know how to migrate in certain kinds of patterns?
That's just built into us?
The awakened brain that we have
allows us to tap into the deep field of consciousness
where there's a unity and then throughout life, right?
I am most of the time you can almost feel the rhythm.
There's a single rhythm and then through life.
Every other living being is tapped
into this field of consciousness.
Every other living being is in deep communication
and aware of one another.
I'll give you an example by way of a story.
One day I'm kayaking down the river by my house.
And it feels so empowering, it feels so good
and it's day with very high waves.
It was one of the highest days, it was March,
right after the thaw in Connecticut where I live.
And suddenly I hear (indistinct).
And two or three geese are looking at me
and then bending their neck way to the side,
(indistinct) as in go right, go right.
And I have to be arrogant beyond words
to not listen to three geese calling in unison
saying go right, so of course I paddled right.
Narrowly to avert a huge,
barely covered cement impediment in the middle of the river.
The geese saved me from capsizing.
They probably saved me from worse, right?
I go further down the river.
New geese (indistinct) again warning me
that there's these deep pylons
right underneath the surface of the river, I steer again.
Further down the river, no more geese.
I hit a pylon, I flip over, you know (indistinct),
kayak full of water.
I look up and there's two humans on the shore.
They look at me flailing in the water with my capsize kayak,
turn their back get in their Mercedes and drive away.
(Lisa and Rich laughing)
we're the only ones.
I wanted to know there was a Mercedes,
it was a nice touch.
Yes, right.
Of course you can't write this stuffs, right?
Yeah, this idea of synchronicity, right?
This idea of when you're present and you're paying attention
and you're cultivating that awareness
that you're enhancing your capability
to tap into this idea of oneness or shared consciousness.
That's almost teetering on kind of a panpsychism idea
of consciousness itself.
Every other living being who I've encountered
is able to tap into this unit of consciousness.
And we have the capacity, we are all endowed
with an awakened brain.
We need to choose to use it
to flip on the switch and to be in deep relationship
with all the other living beings.
I can tell you a hundred stories where this has yet to be...
The switch is still on in childhood.
So young children up until really puberty,
when they get a strong message
that this deep form of awareness isn't real
is really the greatest violation
our culture hands a young adult.
That your deep unity with all life isn't real.
But up until that point,
children are in relationship with all living beings.
And I'll give you one more...
May I share one more story?
Yeah sure.
Okay, my oldest son Isaiah,
who's in the story, he is in The Awakened Brain.
When he was about six years old maybe seven
and he found a dead bird in our yard.
Stiff dead bird.
So he did what most children naturally do,
which is he made a burial for the bird.
And Isaiah's way of honoring the life of the bird
was to take a shoe box line it with soft leaves.
It looked almost like an Egyptian funeral pyre,
gently placed the bird into this box
and send the bird down the road...
It looked like the Nile moving down the river.
This bird and this beautifully lined soft coffin,
if you will.
(indistinct) suddenly in unison.
Dozens, it felt like hundreds,
but dozens of birds (indistinct)
are marking the transition of the bird
from this life to the next.
I didn't know that there were that many birds
surrounding our home.
I would have never with my naked eye
have seen these birds up in the trees
but we heard them.
And I've heard so many accounts
of animals honoring the transition
between this life and the next
for one another and for other living beings.
So we are the ones who've gouged out our eyes.
We are the ones who are deaf to the call
that every other animal hears.
And we have a choice, we're already built with what we need
to dial right back in to the family of life.
We already built to be in relationship with birds,
to be in relationship with geese and all other animals.
Yes, we're in relationship with our own dog
and maybe our cat.
But if you can be close to your dog,
then certainly you can be close to a goat
or a cow or a squirrel, right?
And when we actually pay attention we find...
Please, one more story.
May I?
Of course, yeah, this is what we're here to do.
Okay, good.
(indistinct) teaching my class at Columbia.
Okay, I started the Spirituality Mind Body Institute
at Columbia.
And we teach courses that are foundationally spiritual
in orientation to human flourishing and recovery
within a psychology department.
The psychological wellness that is derived
through our spiritual awareness.
And in this class are probably 40 graduate students
and we're talking about respect for all life, right?
And the importance of being in relationship
to our sisters and brothers,
whether the four legged, the winged.
And right as we tell this story there's a cockroach,
a New York cockroach running through the floor
under the feet of the students.
And one by one they're were like (indistinct).
(Lisa laughing)
And picking up their bags and one of them...
and (indistinct), "No don't kill it, don't kill it."
And this cockroach is running around
and they're lifting and spinning their chairs.
And finally I said, "This is a lived synchronicity
who is amongst us."
And they said, "Well, the cockroach?"
I said, "The fellow living being."
And once everyone in the room started referring to our guest
as the fellow living being.
The fellow living being came up to the front
of the classroom and I do not exaggerate,
took the front, if you will, leg and it went like this.
It was almost like a salute.
(Rich laughing)
It saluted and then took off, goodbye guys.
Okay, so this depth of consciousness
I would say our smartest place.
This deep intuitive sense where you can be
in France or China, India,
you don't need to speak the same language
but you know of the heart what the fellow persons about
and what they're saying to you
and how they feel if they have your best interest in mind.
Our smartest part it has been my experience
is in every living being.
And we can use our heart, our deep knowing,
our awakened heart to be in connection with all life.
The child does this naturally.
It doesn't take that much practice
for us to reawaken what's ours.
Yeah, that's what I wanna get into.
I mean, what's fascinating about the stories you just told
and kind of your overall story
is that what you just shared could be considered
relatively kind of (indistinct).
But you're not somebody who's teaching yoga
and lived on an Ashram.
Like you're reared in a very achievement
oriented environment.
You're very accomplished.
You're a hard scientist.
And you've arrived at this perspective through
some pretty rigorous science,
initially through the lens of depression,
particularly childhood depression
to identify these spiritual markers
and the impact that they have on mental health.
So maybe walk me through how you came to be interested
in this field to begin with?
And may I share amongst my stories
now that you've heard the ones with lots of visuals.
A scientific story to answer your question.
In identifying the converging layers of science
that point to our awakened brain as inherent to who we are,
our awakened brain is necessary to our flourishing
and wholeness and performance.
We use multiple, multiple levels of analysis.
It started with epidemiology and epidemiology of course,
is the practice through which you effectively look out
the window of the airplane at 10,000 feet
and you identify patterns.
The lights are on in this village,
the lights are off in that village.
What might be said about the use of power and energy
between the two villages?
Well patterns, right?
And looking at patterns through the lens of epidemiology.
I was a risk and resilience scientist.
I wanted to know what was the pathway to health?
What was the pathway to recovery?
And normally we'd say, "Well, look here,
if you have good parents,
you are 20% less likely to become depressed.
We'll look here,
if your needs are provided for,
if you have enough material resources,
you are 15% less likely to become depressed."
Using the standard model,
this epidemiological risk and resilience model.
But I asked the question back in 1997,
first time this was ever published.
How does a child do if there's a strong spiritual life
in the family?
Where you castigated for even asking that question?
More like teased and these people were my friends
and they taunted me mercilessly, right?
Actually to be honest people who didn't know me
would walk out of grand rounds presentations.
It was not the taste or the appetite.
It wasn't the culture of science.
Ground rounds being where you share
all the work that you're doing with your peers?
Yes, (indistinct) at that point
I was relatively junior and people who I so admired
in the scientific community got up,
walked up the aisle, exited the double doors and then slam.
I'm not interested in spirituality.
(Rich and Lisa laughing)
So that I took I had a choice, right?
I could either decide,
"Wow, these people who are so successful as scientists
they don't like this I better quit and change.
I could play to the crowd, right?"
But I took the evocativeness of the topic
and the complete absence.
I mean, it was a very arid dry desert.
There was not one published peer review article
on spirituality and mental health
in the first two decades of life.
That's when (indistinct) for the lifetime course.
So I took this to me in the work needed to be done.
And I took the complete disdain of some scientists
who not on scientific grounds
but as a matter of taste and appetite,
didn't take to the topic.
Sure, which is fundamentally anti-scientific, right?
To allow that kind of bias or preconceived notion
of what spirituality is or is not.
Or the impact that it may or may not have
to just be dismissive altogether from the outset
is not really an objective way of looking at problems.
That's not science, right?
That's scientism that's sort of like you say,
a bias, a flavor of the month.
Right now we're not studying spirituality.
What's hot and big in science is we are studying parenting,
or we are...
But I took that disdain as evidenced
the work needed to be done.
And so that was my choice.
So I wasn't gonna to play to the crowd.
I was going to pursue the thing that I knew
in my deep inner wisdom
was healing and helpful to young adults.
What was also...
What was the catalyst beneath that?
Like why were you interested in this to begin with?
I mean, I know you spent time early in your career
in various institutions seeing how mental patients
were treated and had a sense that things might not be
being managed as well as could be or should be.
I often in The Awakened Brain telling the story
of being on a New York City in-patient unit.
I call it unit six because it was very typical of the time.
So I don't wanna lay a trip on those people.
But there were people who were simply not getting better
on unit six.
Who had been admitted 3, 5, 7 times to the hospital
and their files...
This was pre-computer were six inches thick.
They weren't getting better and treatment as usual
was leading to suffering after decades and decades
of nowhere.
And so I noticed that patients were pulling me aside,
knowing that I was interested in hearing about their
spiritual life.
Knowing that I was interested in hearing about
this wellspring of hope in this place of deeper awareness.
I'll give you an example.
This fellow who had been admitted 11 times,
diagnosed with schizophrenia hiding behind the door,
when they jumped out and said, "Dr. Miller."
And I startled and he said, "Come here I have to talk."
And so he pulls me back behind the door with him
and he says, "You need to understand something.
They say I have schizophrenia, yeah, I do.
But there is the world, little T and the world, capital T.
And when things get so painful in little T, the world,
that I can't take it anymore,
then I move to the world capital T.
Where Mother Mary is my mother and I am Jesus."
He was well aware that he was moving
between levels of consciousness.
When one was too painful he was going to another.
But he was doing what many people struggle with.
And this is people with and without diagnosis
hanging out at the level of consciousness
that feels better as opposed to
the level of consciousness that is actually
a place of clarity and discovery and awakening.
So he was aware that he was putting his hand
on the mental gear shift.
Getting out of the daily living that was too painful
by living at a level of consciousness
that was not apropos for the moment, right?
And this was going...
Again, I was pulled into a kitchen once by a woman.
40 years in in-patient.
And she was about to be sent upstate,
which is a little bit of a death sentence
in the mental health world.
"Dr. Miller, will you come with me?"
And we're not talking just the kitchen and the pantry,
way, way back.
She pulled me to the pots and pans room
so that no one could hear us.
And there she said, "Dr. Miller, tomorrow I go upstate."
Clear and strong.
Nothing diluted, nothing psychotic.
She said, "Will you pray with me before I go?"
Now she happened to be Catholic, I'm not Catholic.
She pulled out her rosary and she started saying the rosary.
Again, she said, "Dr. Miller will you pray your way?"
She didn't want me to pretend to be Catholic.
She didn't want me to say the rosary.
She wanted me to speak from my spiritual heart for her.
And as we prayed for one another,
she prayed for me.
She was going upstate and she prayed for me.
This 28 year old intern on the Upper West Side of New York.
"Please God watch over Dr. Miller when I go upstate."
That's a generous heart.
No one else prayed for me that day.
Yeah, that sense of selflessness and altruism.
Deep love.
That is part of that awakened brain state.
On the precipice of going for,
One Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest, right?
Well, that's what's missing.
The reason we have One Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest.
The reason we have 11 admissions.
The reason we have people who don't get better
from recurrent depression
or who in their process of recovery are stuck
is because we have shut down awakened awareness.
Our culture has shut down our innate capacity
to feel this deep love and connection,
this and in through all of life
with fellow living beings with one another.
Our ability to get out of painful times like now, right now.
Right now half the people in the United States
are depressed.
It's time for us to reawaken.
Biden's flipped the switch back on,
the country is supposed to go back to work
and everyone's still slogging around depressed.
And we have a choice.
We can hold in a state of depression.
We can devolve into a deeper depression, a major depression.
We can try to take away the sharp edges
of course, with substances.
Or we can try to use this moment of despair
as an invitation to an awakening.
And we are hardwired to be able to use suffering
as an impetus for growth.
In fact, trauma is a catalyst for growth.
Every bit of data says that to be the case.
So how do we do that?
Practically sounds good.
I'd love to stop being depressed.
How do we do that?
There are hardwired ways
immediately quarter-inch under the surface
that we can turn back on
to use suffering as the catalyst for growth.
To use our struggle as a moment of awakening.
And one of them first and foremost,
is to start to take seriously
our inner experience as hard data.
From the time that we were very young children
we're taught that what's real.
And it's the same mistake
that we were just talking about Rich,
that the idea that scientists had a taste and appetite
for things that were actually...
You touch it, can you see it?
Where's the taste and appetite for the transcendent,
for the spiritual?
Well, we've been educated out of our awakened awareness.
We've been educated out of our spiritual awareness.
The first thing I've found and I've worked with hundreds,
probably now thousands of people
is that we need to honor again our inner wisdom.
That what is real is outer.
This bottle's real and there you sit before me
and the camera's real and all this is real.
But so too is the deep knowing of a mystical experience,
of our intuition, of our gut instincts.
These forms of knowing need to be honored
and integrated with empiricism and logic.
We teach young children starting in kindergarten
that how do you know that point on the page
to how you know it?
Don't tell me you just know that.
But there is such a thing as spontaneous awareness
and direct knowing.
Don't tell me it came to you in some type of dream, right?
But that is a very powerful...
I mean, we know through all sacred texts
that important knowledge comes through dreams.
Yeah, but our culture over indexes
on the mind over the heart, right?
And we're taught from the outset
that to indulge the hearts messages
is to be blind to what the head is telling us.
And all of our social signaling directs us
to pay attention to mining the development of the head
and ultimately the corresponding muting of the hearts.
And so it isn't until we face a trauma or a struggle.
If we're not habituated to kind of being heart-centered,
it isn't until we have some kind of life altering problem
or we suffer a loss or something happens to us
that we're compelled out of pain as you mentioned earlier,
to kind of indulge that aspect of who we are?
And therein lies like the opportunity
to kind of re-emerge more whole out of such an experience.
And the science mirrors this truth.
This is a absolute fact what you say Rich.
That we looked at people with a very deep,
strong personal spirituality.
Some were religious, some were not.
Catholic, Hindu, Jewish, Muslim.
Spiritual but not religious.
People with a deep spiritual compass.
We're two and a half times more likely
in the past 10 years to have suffered deep despair.
So while we can strengthen our spiritual core in many ways
and there are many paths to awakening very often,
it is exactly as you describe it as through suffering.
That the world as we know it doesn't hold,
the ground shifts, it cracks under our feet.
And there is a deeper look into life.
And when we do look more closely,
we see there is a unitiness.
We see that life actually is buoyant and has our back.
That there's something in life that is actually guiding.
Life is very much alive and conscious.
This realization and we put people in the MRI.
People who to recover from depression
through a deepening of spiritual life.
And what we found was that they had thick cortex.
The cortex is processing power across regions of perception,
reflection and orientation.
They think effectively had strengthened the biceps
of their spiritual awareness through suffering.
And once they did, once they were strong for the next lift,
the next time something very heavy was thrown their way.
There were 75% protected against recurrence.
And that went up to 90% if they were otherwise at high risk.
High risk, meaning a genetically predisposed,
high risk meaning really thrown a lot of tough stuff
in life.
So when we choose to struggle to grow,
when in fact despair is an awakening time
we are armored against subsequent depressions.
And not only that but we look into life
in a much more expansive and eliminated way.
There's much more upside.
Let's go deeper into the hard science piece
of how you've drawn these conclusions.
Because I think it's super interesting
like figuring out how to devise these studies
and the process of taking people through this
procedure with FMRIs to kind of discover
what you've discovered.
So the first thing is that when I looked
through the lens of epidemiology,
I saw that the magnitude of the protective benefits
of a personal spirituality,
how much it keeps us healthy and safe
as compared to anything else we had identified in science
was at least three fold greater, right?
So if we have good parents,
we're 20% less likely to get depressed, right?
If we have a strong personal spirituality,
we are 80% less likely to become addicted
using DSM criteria.
80%, right?
That's so a young-
I mean, that's in scientific parlance
that's like off the chained.
Off the chart.
Nothing is 80%.
Right.
But the standard deviation above
as compared to below the mean
and a tendency to say my personal spirituality
is highly important to me.
Nature is a sacred home.
I turned to God for guidance in times of difficulty.
My family is spiritual to me.
So the sense of daily lived spiritual awareness
turning on the awakened brain,
walking each day with this deeper understanding
and look into life.
Turning the lens into that level of resolution.
That is 80% protective.
When we're going through the window of risk for onset,
which is laid out adolescence and emerging adulthood.
So that is so huge.
Well, and Rich when it comes to despair and suffering,
right now the number one killer of young adults
in our country is suicide.
A young adult 19 year old is more likely to die
by his or her own hand than in an auto accident.
So if we're gonna say to our kids buckle up.
We've got to get ahead of this.
And it's pushing down now into middle school.
Well, there's a meta analysis.
A study of studies conducted by (indistinct) colleagues
that showed a 62% decreased
relative risk of completed suicide.
And that goes to 82% when our spiritual awareness
is shared in a group.
We've got to look at one another
and see the presence of God, spirit.
Consciousness in one another
and we've got to speak about it and live that way.
We are dying as a culture
because we have shut off our awakened brain.
But if we listen to one another
and see one another as spiritual beings,
souls on earth, children of God,
you pick your language, right?
Then we have a shot.
Yeah, I mean, it seems that given the data
that you just shared it would be elementary
that some aspect of this education
be built into the experience of young people
as they emerge in the adolescents.
So they have a basis point or at least a vernacular
around these ideas and these practices.
So they can be self-sufficient or at least equipped
with tools to go on their own exploration as they mature.
But that's just not part of our educational system.
But it can be.
Yeah, I mean, there's a lot of separation
of church and state and the sort of confusing confluence
of religion with spirituality.
Like it becomes very complicated
and perhaps even politicized to even discuss this, right?
(indistinct chatter)
We have the politics exit the room, right?
And if you can only from science and young people surviving
and not killing themselves, right?
Young people surviving and being at peace within themselves
then let's look just squarely at the science.
And the science says we are all innately spiritual beings.
With or without the embrace of religion.
We are all born with the spiritual core.
And if we build the spiritual core,
we have physical fitness for the physical core.
We need spiritual fitness for the spiritual core.
And if we do we are 80% less likely to be addicted,
60% less likely to take our lives.
We're able to be whole and thrive.
We have disintegrated the spiritual core
from the rest of the person and disintegration is unhealth.
So how do we put the spiritual core back in?
Well, if it's a public school or the public square,
it's minus religion.
That can happen at home.
But spirituality exists independent of religion.
And how can we do that?
Again at home the religious embrace of spiritual awareness
is important for many families.
Roll with it, do that at home.
But in a public school we can strengthen the muscle
of transcendent awareness, of spiritual values
towards one another.
And in fact, when we look in the MRIs
at the neural correlates of the awakened brain,
of all forms of spiritual practice
that which most correlates with a strong
spiritual awareness is love of neighbor.
Love of neighbor and service altruism.
That can be part of every classroom.
Circle time where they were five years old
or sophomore year by the locker.
Of all people on earth,
you were put next to your classmate
who struggles with low IQ.
Your classmate doesn't really know how to talk to people,
your classmate maybe it's a little awkward.
Where you put there to bully her
and make her feel horrible or where you put there
perhaps as some form of inspiration or guide?
Might you even be what I call a trail angel for her.
We can recast who we are to each other
as helpers and healers.
Love, guided, help and never alone.
Can we show up that way for one another?
And that can be taught in school.
But the other things that need to be taught
that are part of our natural awakened awareness
or listening to our inner wisdom is hard data.
And we need to reboot our capacity
for transcendent awareness in a way that is inclusive,
certainly constitutional and in the language of life.
And there are practices in The Awakened Brain
for reawakening our brain.
But we could do one if you wanna do one.
Yeah, we can do.
You going do it?
Great.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is one I wanted to honor my teachers,
as I think as in many traditions.
This was taught to me by the late Gary Weaver.
And I've done this exercise with thousands of people
none of him have ever felt offended
because it's in the language of life.
And I do this with the U S Army
and I do this with people on Wall Street
and I do this in homeless shelters.
I do this everywhere.
All right, let's do it.
Let's do it, okay.
I'm going to invite you to clear out your inner space,
five breaths and then we'll do about a 92nd visualization.
Okay?
Five breaths.
(Lisa and Rich breathing)
I invite you to set before you a table.
This is your table.
And to your table you may invite anyone living or deceased
who truly has your best interest in mind.
Anybody living or deceased
And with them all sitting there ask them if they love you?
And now you may invite your higher self,
your true eternal higher self.
The part of you that's much more than anything
you've done or not done.
Anything that you have or don't have.
Your true higher self.
And to ask you if you love you.
And now finally, you may invite your higher power,
whatever word that may be.
However you know you are higher power
and ask your higher power if they love you?
And now with all of those people sitting there right now,
what do they need to share?
What do they need to let you know?
What do you need to know right now?
And when you're ready I invite you back.
This is your council.
And they're always there for you.
Who shows up may change depending on where you are
in your road of life.
And you can ask them different questions
depending on where you are in your road of life.
But your higher self, your higher power,
and those who truly have your best interest in mind.
This is a form of deep awakened awareness.
This is the deep loving consciousness
that flows in in-between us and through us.
And we are built to be able to see
and know this level of love and relationship.
That's beautiful.
I love it.
A way of connecting with a sense of community
and support also to feel appreciated, feel loved.
Loved, never alone and guided.
So that deep awareness we are loved, guided and never alone.
We have flipped back on our ability to know and see that.
It was true whether or not we paid attention,
just like I could have paid attention or not paid attention
to the never alone connected, guided by the geese.
Right.
It's true as embodied by one another.
And it's true in our direct transcendent awareness.
Sorry to interrupt the flow.
We'll be right back with more awesome.
But first I do want to snag a quick moment
to talk about something I care a lot about
which is the importance of nutrition.
And the thing is most people I know actually aspire
to eat better, to incorporate more whole plants,
fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans and lagoons,
into their daily regimen.
Sadly, however, without the proper tools and support
very few end up sticking with it.
And so because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly.
And because I want everyone to experience
some version of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
And the solution we've devised I'm proud to say
is the Plantpower Meal Planner are affordable,
all-in-one digital platform that sets you up
for nutrition excellence by providing access
to thousands of customizable, super delicious,
easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery.
You get access to our team of amazing nutrition coaches,
seven days a week and many, many other amazing features.
To kickstart your health intentions this New Year,
we're offering you $20 off,
a one-year membership with the code POWER20
throughout the entire month of January.
Again, that's promo code POWER20 for $20 off
@meals.richroll.com.
All right, back to the pod.
How does this go when you do this with the Army?
They love it.
Do they?
I have-
I'm so interested in your work with the military.
Oh, it's so...
I have to tell you that it has been profoundly moving,
the work with the military.
First of all, the military is a highly innovative
data-driven creative institution.
I have seen such love and care
at the highest levels of the Army.
I delivered the science in The Awakened Brain
to the four-stars, the vice chief, the chief
and the Secretary of the Army.
Wow.
At the Pentagon in a back quiet room.
No, shit.
In a split second they all got it.
They were deeply aware of what the science said
about the hundreds of thousands of young soldiers
in their care.
The four-stars it was a very interesting.
One man who has trained 300,000 soldiers
within the last couple of years said,
"There's not a single thing in the science
that surprises me.
This is a mirror of the challenges we face right now.
Which is we've never seen young adults show up on day one,
as fragile as given to despair and struggle.
And this is indeed the way through.
We strengthen the physical core,
we strengthen the mental core.
We must strengthen the spiritual core."
So for two years I've worked very closely
with the leadership of the Pentagon
to develop spiritual readiness.
We call it the Spiritual Readiness Initiative.
We've been to Fort Bragg, we've been to Fort Jackson.
We've been to Fort Hood, Fort Leonard Wood, everywhere.
I have not seen one commander, general, lieutenant,
nobody who has felt nerved or uncomfortable.
The science mirrors what in a deep human way,
they have already felt experienced.
And the science being that cultivating this awakened mind
allows you to in turn develop grit,
perseverance, sense of community, a sense of altruism,
all of these things that the military relies upon
in order for it to be successful in its campaign
and kind of create a cohesion amongst it's union of people.
The military on day one who shows up at the door?
The military gets big slice of American pie
and the challenges they face or the challenges
that are not merely the militaries.
I hear the same thing that I hear in the military
when it comes to rates of suicide,
when it comes to despair,
when it comes to breaches of relational ethics.
Like sexual assault, racism and extremism.
The very same things the military struggles with,
I see in higher education.
In many of our most admired institutions, same problems.
And I also see it in my work
with large private sector companies
taking an 18 through 25 year olds.
They say our young adults have never been more fragile.
We don't know how to train them
because the fear of failure is so great.
They hide their weekly records.
We don't even know what they're doing.
And if you push them they crumble, they'll quit.
Right, exactly.
So the fragility, the rates of depression,
addiction and suicide.
And the inability to bond and connect
and with that inability to feel brotherhood
and sisterhood is on tough days,
real anger at times even violation of one another.
This is not the military challenge alone
it's our American challenge.
But the military is leading away in a data-driven approach
using the science in The Awakened Brain
to address really the plague
that has attacked young adults.
The inner plague, the diseases of despair.
I mean, our kids, I have three teenagers
I know very well what's going on right now.
There has never been such suffering, such loneliness,
a genuine isolation.
And they're trying so hard.
They're so kind and gentle to one another,
the culture of Gen Z.
And they speak to each other
almost like a parent speaks to a young baby.
"Okay honey, don't worry about it."
Because they're in such pain.
But the military is actually doing something
institutionally to transform the environment
around young adults.
And they're saying, "We've got to move
from a culture here in the Army."
But certainly this is generalizable
to every other institution.
Where our culture is one
where we treat each other transactionally.
I'm your boss, perform for me?
I am your teacher,
let's see if you mastered the material, right?
We've got to move from relationships
that are merely transactional
to relationships that are transformational.
Now, 50 years ago that was actually in the air and water
that there was a general activity implicit
and really almost morally incumbent upon the boss
or the teacher.
But as we've moved to narrow performance as the goal
and narrow outcome and success,
we have lost what we just experienced in the visualization.
Which is a sense of one another's higher self.
And I'm sure that's exacerbated
by the virtual work environment
that we're all contending with right now.
Where it's just the occasional Zoom call
and then it's performance metrics
and it's all about whether
you're hitting your numbers or not.
And there is no real deep emotional relationship
amongst coworkers and kind of hierarchy in the work place.
It's purely transactional, right?
It's really capitalism as a moral or relational theory.
Capitalism is an economic theory,
but it's trickled down into our relational fabric
and it's lonely and it's isolating.
The problem is that the young adults
who were raised in this culture today
have not developed the biceps.
Have not built the muscle of the form of awakened awareness,
the transcendent awareness that sees spirit
and goodness or godliness in one another.
That sees this deep sense of brotherhood and sisterhood
even if we're in intensive competition
or today we had a very serious argument.
Is there a deeper landing pad,
a deeper seat of human experience we share.
That's just not there.
And I mean, young adults have never been so lonely.
And because of the feeling of isolation,
the very real sense of being unsafe in the world, right?
The fix it have all been in the band
of what I call achieving awareness.
We've got to handle this by strategizing better.
And we've got to handle this by coming up with
solutions where we distribute money differently.
And we've got to figure out ways of
working in a way where people are punished
when they do things that are wrong.
And they're working in this narrow band
of yesterday's thinking.
But if we're gonna solve this problem here
then we need a new form of thinking
and good news is we're hardwired for it.
We just haven't used it.
We need to use our awakened awareness.
Yeah, it's about going to the yesterday
before yesterday's thinking.
There's an ancient kind of indigenous truth
in cultivating spiritual practice
that we have kind of just considered to be archaic.
And yet on some level we could talk about neuroscience
and all of that.
I wanna get into that.
But a lot of this is going back
to what we intuitively know and cultivated
in earlier incarnations of civilization.
There was such a sense of duty and love
the elder had for the younger that's missing, right?
If a student is in a classroom of 400 students
and comes up to the professor.
The professor needs to see that child far from home
as someone's precious daughter or son.
The professor has to see that that is an emerging adults
seeking truth not just trying to master chemistry
or philosophy or psychology.
And the sense that we are mentors and guides
for one another in higher ed is almost gone.
Has become transactional.
The Army as compared to any other institution I've seen,
has the greatest commitment to being fathers and mothers
for their children.
May I say many of our soldiers come from houses not homes.
And we have...
There's two paths to the Army.
One is a passion to serve
and the other is running from a horrible situation.
And both paths can lead to an outstanding soldier
and a strong military career.
There's a possibility for renewal for deepening
that we're more than just what we brought to the table
on day one.
The Army cultivates young men and women.
I can tell you there are Republicans or Democrats.
There're people from the West Coast, the East Coast,
everybody's in the Army.
It is a big slice of American pie.
The felt sense of brotherhood and sisterhood
is extraordinary
And when I shared the science of The Awakened Brain
with a tank commander, with a commanding general,
with 40,000 people.
No matter who I share the science with,
they're saying, "Hey, wait a minute.
This is the form of deep connection.
This is the form of human love and bonding."
That is really the glue and the Army family.
We can do what the Army is doing
in our other institutions, in large corporations
in higher ed, we can do this.
But we've got to own our responsibility to one another.
Yeah, it's almost as if the success
that the Army is having with this type of modeling
could prove to be a Harvard Business School
case study that could be replicated
in corporate America and in educational institutions.
It is so readily transferable
what the Army has discovered.
The Armies used the science of The Awakened Brain,
and in a top-down vertically integrated way.
They've said through all levels of training.
Whether it's basic training or time at promotion.
Or when one moves into the second half of one's career
and is responsible for thousands of other people,
there needs to be a form of spiritual growth
and strengthening.
The more responsibility we have for other people's lives
the more we need to make awakened decisions
when their lives are on the line.
And when you listen to people
in the very top echelons of the Pentagon,
they speak in terms of knowing
deep in their inner awareness.
The most important decision I ever made
was to get into that helicopter.
And it wasn't driven out of logic alone
or out of the numbers alone.
I just had an inner intuition.
It was in my inner wisdom,
my heart that I knew to get on that helicopter.
And I saved six people's lives.
It's so counterintuitive in so many ways because
the military is premised upon chain of command, right?
It doesn't matter what your intuition is telling you.
You do what I tell you to do.
You following lockstep with your orders.
Well, he or she who gives orders,
gives better orders when they use their awakened brain.
And in fact, the role of making an awakened decision
it was something that the leadership took to immediately.
There's an awareness that...
Well, let's tell it through the MRI stories.
Yeah, I mean, I wanna...
Let's get into the neuroscience
because I don't wanna talk about the areas of the brain
that get lit up or that get turned off and all of that.
First of all, constructing the study,
like how do you come up with what the study is going to be?
And then you're putting people into the FMRIs.
We should talk about what an FMRI is
and what it can tell us?
And what you discover about these different areas
of the brain and how they're impacted
by cultivating the awakened mind, the awakened brain?
So that is an elegant way to ask the question
and I can't wait to respond to it.
All right, so using the lens of epidemiology,
it was clear that those threads of lived human spirituality
which are protective against addiction,
which are part of our strengthening and deepening
in the path of recovery and renewal
from trauma or depression
where this sense of transcendent relationship, right?
The capacity to perceive transcendent relationship
and that might be shared.
So knowing that through the lens of epidemiology
there was something heritable built into us.
A form of spiritual awareness
that had such an huge impact on our health and wellness.
It seemed that we could try to operationalize
that dimension as a task in the MRI scanner and live action,
watch people engaged in a deep transcendent relationship.
So that's what we did.
We sat around the table for 18 months
and used previously validated ways of working
an MRI studies to come up with an in-scanner task
that represented that thread that had been identified
over 10 years of epidemiological work.
And here's how we worked together.
The Spirituality Mind Body Institute,
my Institute together with Mark (indistinct)
and (indistinct) at Yale,
together literally for a year.
We sat around and figured out the method.
And then for another six months operationalized it.
And here's how we did it-
18 months just to devise the experiment.
Yes, because the most meaningful part
of a research study is the question and its method, right?
This has never been done before.
And in fact, scientists has said,
"You can't operationalize spirituality.
It's too broad and vast."
And that's where using multiple levels of inquiry,
bringing a finding from epidemiology into an MRI scanner
allowed us to make progress as well as working between labs.
The Manhattan Project didn't have one guy,
or one woman's lab is collaboration.
So (indistinct) had found over 15 years
that when we tell a story, a memory,
in a way that's very palpable and rich
and has lots of sensory points real anchors in it
that bring us back in time.
We elicit the same neural correlates as if we were there
plus memory, right?
And Mark (indistinct) working with (indistinct)
had become one of the leading experts around addiction.
And he had found that the addiction loop in our brain,
the insulin striatum is the same.
Whether we are addicted to alcohol and drugs
or pornography and the internet or gambling, it's the same.
I've got to have it, right?
So they had worked together,
(indistinct) and Mark in the past,
developing this in-scanner task when it came to craving.
When it came to telling stories of addiction,
hungry and I need to have the drug, I need to have...
I've got to get to Vegas,
I've got to have this roll of the dice.
Well, when I approached them I said,
"We know from epidemiology that there's nothing
that's protective against addiction there's a strong,
personal spirituality.
Can we watch that in the scanner?"
And of course, as open-minded creative scientists,
Mark and (indistinct) were thrilled.
We sat down for a year and a half
and we took the following question
after a year and a half of inquiry
to 18 to 25 year olds.
We said, "Tell us a time when you felt a deep connection
with your higher power."
Some people say God, Jesus, Allah, Hashem.
Some people say the universe or a oneness with all life.
But tell us a time where you felt a deep connection
with a deeper, deeper presence of life
that was loving and guiding.
Nobody was confused.
18 to 25 year olds in New Haven.
A lot of them were Yale students.
A lot of them were agnostic.
Some spiritual but not religious.
Some not friendly to the whole idea of religion.
Nobody was surprised, everyone had an important experience.
Everyone.
And then how many people?
What was the population size?
Well, okay so in order to...
And an MRI studies is there's often very small samples.
You can even publish study with like 10.
But we had about 30 people
who went through every phase of this study.
And in this study, whether they were Christian, Catholic,
Jewish, Muslim, Hindu, spiritual but not religious.
No matter what their background was,
the same neural correlates ran
as they told us that narrative.
And what is a neural correlate?
So as they...
As we wanted to be very precise.
We literally knew at what point in their study
they felt this unit of experience.
So we had them tell their stories.
This is part of (indistinct) method over 15 years.
Tell the story, tell it again while it's audio taped,
play it back in earbuds in the MRI machine
while the FMRI is running so that we can pinpoint
to the T what neural correlates are seeing.
What happens in the MRI as you say
this specific little passage in your story.
And right at the point where the young adults would say,
"I'm walking down the street.
I'm completely depressed.
I've just been turned down
at five out of six medical schools.
I'm such a loser,
I'm never gonna be a doctor like my mother."
But then suddenly I see light in the leaves.
And I know that God has a plan for me.
Or suddenly I see light in the leaves,
and I know that life is buoyant
and I will be a healer in the way I am intended.
Or suddenly I see light in the leaves,
and I know that there's a path for me
greater than anything I know yet.
That aha, the reshuffling of meaning
is eliminated and speaks to a true part of myself.
Right as that part of the narrative is told.
We saw coming up online four major components
of what we're calling the awakened brain.
The first is that quieting I'm such a loser,
quieting the racket.
The default mode is powered down.
Now that you can do through mindfulness.
That's simply getting present.
That's the network of rumination.
Exactly.
Right.
Right, now very often because we have a hungry culture.
Many people are taught mindfulness to get present
and it's helpful but it only stops there.
It only gets us present.
When in fact, what then is potentiated
is that we are at a threshold to cross for being present
into a state of awakened awareness.
It's mindfulness plus it's crossing into.
And the next three loops are first and foremost.
Just as we were held as children
in our parents, or grandparents arms
we feel loved, we feel held, the bonding network is engaged
and we are aware that life itself is holding.
The next is the parietal.
That's the frontotemporal network.
Yes, yes, exactly, right?
So that was the...
Yes, that was the article.
And in fact that...
Well, I'll tell the whole story (indistinct).
Then the next piece to come online is the parietal
to put in and out hard boundaries.
So just as there's a sense of discrete
in specific experiences.
You have your path, you live in California,
you love your family, you look like you.
And I live in Connecticut and I love my family...
We are distinct, we are magnificently diverse,
we are different.
And at the same time,
there's a deep common unit of experience,
a common human heart.
The parietal lobe puts in and out hard boundaries
so that we can toggle between a sense of difference
and common love, common felt being.
And then the final piece which is-
But just to put a finer point on that.
Reduced activity in the parietal lobe
allows the influx of this sense of commonality among all.
Is that right?
Yes.
Is that fair?
That we are connected or one.
Exactly.
And then finally, this is a particular importance
to innovation, to decision-making.
The Army's really championed
this dimension of awakened awareness.
We move from a narrow top down dorsal attention network,
tactical, strategical.
We've got to get out the red door.
We've planned, we're prepared, everybody's trained,
we're going out the red door.
But today here live the red doors jammed.
We can't get out.
That's a metaphor of course for life.
Everything was in the bag, A plus B plus C,
of course it was me who was gonna be promoted.
And then they what?
They brought in somebody.
Or A plus B plus C.
I was the one it was my turn to be quarterback.
It was my turn to be on the varsity football team.
And what?
I got cut?
So it all didn't add up.
The red door stuck.
And because the red door stuck
we shift in a state of awakened awareness
from the top down narrow
bowling alley perception of the dorsal
to the bottom of ventral attention network.
We have a much broader field of perception,
far more information.
And many people say that the right answer,
the new possibility pops the yellow door.
Never would have seen the yellow door.
But the yellow door leads to a landscape
that was surprising.
That could be magnificently
in the big sense of the word prosperous.
I meet the person who I am best friends with
the rest of my life.
I find a line of work I never dreamed of.
I ended up in a city that was so very much at home.
The yellow door opens
and that possibility of bottom-up perception
leads to a form of creativity and innovation
the Army calls situational awareness.
That allows us to align with the way life really is.
You can see the whole chess board
as opposed to the one piece that you can't move
the way that you want it to move.
Yes, and your opponent played something you never dreamed
based on the books he play, right?
That's why it's harder to play that opponent
than a good one, right?
But that's the real chess board that's actually here now.
And when we have actual alignment with life...
What is life showing me now?
What is the chess board actually telling me now?
We're able to make much better decisions.
So much of suffering in life
comes from being out of alignment with deep truth.
Much of our own happiness comes,
our joy comes from asking the question,
what is life showing me now?
And being surprised finding yellow doors.
And yellow doors can be people we never know we'd meet...
Can I tell you a story?
Yeah, you're telling my story right now but go ahead.
Oh, I wanna hear your story.
No, no one wants to hear my story.
But I'm so connected to what you're saying
because this has been my own personal journey
that I had to figure out for myself
as somebody who like you,
grew up in a traditional trajectory
of being addicted to achievement and success
as a means of acceptance and love
like a marker for love and all of that.
And kind of running the gamut with that
and bottoming out and having problems
with drugs and alcohol and getting sober
and then having an existential crisis.
And it's been this very slow, glacially slow process
of trying to reconcile heart and mind
so that they could live in unison with each other.
And it's been a journey of trying to connect with
that situational awareness
and paying attention to what my heart was telling me
even if it was at odds with everything that I ever knew
or everything that I thought was right or correct for me.
And this kind of battle or war that took place
with inside of myself that finally led me to a place
of such pain that I almost felt like I had no choice
but to engage with the heart in a way that I hadn't before.
And a trust and a faith that that would direct me
in a way that this other way of living couldn't
that has created the situation that I'm in today,
over many years and not in any kind of linear fashion
but truly it has been a journey of reckoning
with the awakened brain that has taken me
from a place of despair into one of deep fulfillment
with what I do and who I am.
Knowing of the heart deploys the strategic
capability of the head.
But the knowing of the heart guides the journey.
Sure, and that's a very difficult-
And we're taught (indistinct) backwards in schools-
Yeah, exactly.
And to do that, to engage with that
is almost an act of great rebellion.
And one that will be criticized and ridiculed
by anybody that you care to share with them.
Because it is completely at odds with how we're taught
to direct our lives.
And yet the rich traditions, indigenous traditions,
spiritual traditions and knowing that the heart discerns
what is true and right.
Our awakened heart.
Yes, but those people were uneducated.
They were brutes.
They didn't know what they were talking about.
Now we know better.
We've had the age of enlightenment.
We've gone through the Renaissance
and we are now in the age of science and reason.
So science and reason is fantastic to implement, right?
The knowing of the heart sets the compass, the direction.
Where there's real value shows us the yellow door.
And then we can discern with the knowing of the head
how best to lay our plans to move through the yellow door.
But we only found it at the heart.
So I think that the heart points to what is true,
and then the head can help us strategize about
how actually to leave the Ashram or the mountain top
and go down and create a beautiful podcast.
Yeah, but the head shouldn't be making those
huge decisions.
The heart should be making those.
And then the head has to figure out
how to kind of guide you towards that thing
that you feel the calling towards.
Because we have overemphasized the head
telling the heart what to do.
We have a donut size hole in our heart as a culture.
And no one feels more pain than our young adults
who are completely immersed in this.
This is a form of disaggregation of our true being.
We are unwhole.
And this is why the young people are suffering
so much right now.
Because we have the authorized and knowing of the heart.
It's tragic.
It is, it is a crime.
You mentioned earlier and you talk about this in the book.
The idea that an individual in young adolescents
is in this prime situation to kind of cultivate
the awakened brain or this deeper awareness.
Like how did you discover that there
is this kind of window of opportunity at that age
for that exploration?
So whether or not anyone ever told me
this is coming at 15, 16.
Suddenly, I wonder if everything you ever told me
mom and dad is true at all.
And everything you ever told me, pastor, priest,
imam or rabbi was that true at all?
So the assumptions of how the world's built
and what is good and what is evil
or if there even is in an ultimate sense good and evil.
These are profound existential questions.
These have to do with the foundation of life, right?
The nature of reality.
It's all a 52 card pickup.
And this happens whether or not
we tell the young adult is coming.
The wisdom traditions, the religious traditions,
the indigenous traditions,
all knew that with biological puberty
and moving into middle and late adolescents,
there was as we change physically and look different,
we change spiritually.
They knew this.
And whether we're talking about Bar and Bat Mitzvah
for the (indistinct), the sweat lodge confirmation,
every tradition marks puberty as a time
of augmented spiritual awareness.
And they were met with rites of passage
to honor that and kind of anchor it.
Precisely and now we know to mirror that deep truth
of humanity through thousands of years.
That when we look through the lens of a twin study,
there's a 50% increase in the heritable contribution
going from middle to late adolescents
of spirituality with or without religion.
So whether or not there is a tradition
to greet the young adult coming of age,
whether or not there is a rite of passage
or a ceremony or a guide.
The young adult hungers for ultimate transcendence
and meaning.
Nagging questions of the head, desires of the heart
for connection, love, illumination, this happens.
But when we leave him or her out there willy nilly,
they're flailing, they're lost.
And what would be a hunt for transcendent truth
devolves into the cheap backdoor of transcendence
through addiction, right?
I get lots of emails from young adults who say,
"I was looking for transcendence.
I was looking for that sense of love and buoyancy.
And I took the tricky back door.
And at first it felt great.
And then I slid further and further down."
Young adults know what this is.
I mean, you've mentioned that the awakened brain
and depression are kind of two sides of the same coin
but what you just mentioned reminds me that
addiction is part of that as well.
It is a flip side and you hear long time in recovery
and there's this sort of adage or trope
in the recovery community that the addict
is the spiritual seeker.
They're just seeking for those answers in unhealthy ways.
But ultimately it's that emptiness,
that hole in the soul that yearning that leads them
towards drugs and alcohol as salve
or as a vehicle for a different state of consciousness
to tap into something that has meaning
outside of individuality.
And so can we show up honestly
for the team in the young adult and say, "I get it.
I appreciate the hunger for transcendence.
That warmth, that felt of buoyant,
that almost had fence of numinousness you can almost see.
That warmth, the joy."
In our day it was the lit lighters at a concert
the whole room had a glow.
And we felt like we were one.
This fence of being one.
I get it.
But do you still feel it the next day?
It felt so great last night.
It felt so connected last night when you were using,
but do you still feel it today
or was it sort of a false way in?
And I think that we need to honor the transcendent hunt
and support the transcendent hunt.
Because when we don't the young adult go shopping
and it can be the false sense of connection
through using drugs and alcohol.
It can also be that going shopping means
they find bad teachers.
And a lot of things that end up looking like extremism
or even terrorism are the young adults
shopping for a spiritual teacher.
We've got to show up,
we've got to know this is coming.
Hardwired, boot it up, look at it through twin studies.
It is absolutely a fact that with puberty
comes spiritual growth, spiritual hunger.
And the extent to which we support as adults
the formation of the spiritual course
extent to which that young adult
is protected against addiction and depression going forward.
Right, so extensively what you're saying is,
with this explosion in adolescent depression
and addiction rates going through the roof.
That part of the antidote or the treatment protocol
has to be cultivation of spiritual awareness
to take people through some protocol
where they can connect with their awakened brain
in some way to ameliorate or combat
the instincts that are leading
towards this mental health crisis
that we're contending with.
And if we do it's a set up for life.
The formative work of late adolescence,
the initial depression, if you will, sophomore slump.
Go back to being a sophomore if you can bear it, okay.
(Lisa laughing)
And I think-
Sophomore in college or high school?
Sophomore in college, sophomore in college.
So I invite everybody to think about
being a sophomore in college and not I'll go first.
I was a sophomore in college and I'd come to college
so confident.
And my mother loved me and my father loved me.
And I had great friends from growing up.
So I got to college and the greatest time I went to parties,
I was dancing and everything was fabulous.
And I met my first boyfriend and I thought,
"Oh, he's so funny.
He's so smart.
I've never met anyone so interesting.
He's a wrestler.
He's so beautiful.
He must really love me."
(Lisa chuckles)
And he said, he loved me.
And it was wonderful.
And we went out for a few months
but then he broke up with me.
And I couldn't believe it.
I said, "Wait, you said you loved me
and now you don't love me anymore?"
He's like, "No, I truly loved you.
I truly did and I just don't feel that now."
I'm like, "Well, how could you have loved me in November
but not love me in February?
How could that be?"
And also how could I not be lovable?
I mean, my mother loves me and my father loves me
and my best friends...
And it set me downward spiraling into this existential quest
that I now understand through science
every 20 year old is primed to have.
The trigger was that my heart was broken.
It was my first terrible breakup.
But the landing was into this deep existential pit.
And I thought, "Well, if we can love each other one day
and not the next then love isn't permanent.
So if love isn't permanent love isn't real."
And actually, I'll call this fellow Jason.
If Jason loved me one day and Jason doesn't the next,
then is there really a Jason?
Is Jason stable?
And this is the type of existential wondering
that the sophomore runs with.
Now some are more prone towards than others.
But these felt sense of here today gone tomorrow
leads to a form of struggling.
And I share in The Awakened Brain,
sophomore year I ended up
in the basement of my dorm at Yale.
Literally in the basement because in the freezing cold
of New Haven in the winter,
there was a hot water boiler in the basement
that it was at least warm.
And I could sit there all night by the hot water boiler
and wonder, "Well, does life have permanence?
And is there meaning written into life?"
And this reached the point which is actually normative.
Does God exist?
I mean, I'd grown up feeling God's presence my whole life
and my mother cries at the presence of God.
But does God exist because Jason broke up with me?
And that is the type of thing that psychotherapists
on college campuses.
Or psychotherapists that work with young adults in general
need to understand doesn't really have an answer
in negotiating our relationships interpersonally.
Doesn't really have an answer and identity work.
Doesn't really have an answer through the lens of the DSM
as an adult adjustment disorder
or some sort of moderate level major depression.
That is a grappling with existential truth
for which we are hardwired.
The trigger differs from person to person.
But wondering what is real?
What is true?
Is there good and evil?
Does love exist?
Does God exist?
Do I matter?
Does Jason matter?
That we are built to do and with that process,
there is a hunger to know the deepest nature of life
and the depression in not knowing the answer.
Yeah, I wonder whether that process
is precipitated more commonly these days
by a more profound sense of despair,
rather than my mother loved me
and why am I not lovable to him?
Isn't it more typical that the young individual
is repeating this narrative of I'm entirely unlovable?
Or I look terrible and I hate my body
and I can't make friends.
It's more of a darker disposition
that is much more kind of dire.
Yes and also mom and dad you say you love me,
but you're handing me a world
that's on the edge of environmental collapse.
Or my teachers say they know things,
but they're handed me a world
that's full of political rifts and immature behavior
amongst adults.
So what...
And I think that the answer is in the young adult.
But it's not in the way that we're talking to them now.
We need a new way of thinking and a new way of engaging
the young adult.
And that way it looks like what?
And that way is you say you can't stand your body.
You say I love you but I wasn't there
in the way you wish I was there for you.
Let's connect with the deepest truest part of yourself.
I invite you to connect into the deepest place
of your inner wisdom from which you can start to receive
and perceive direct awareness of the yellow door
of a way forward.
We have shut out the young adult from her or his resource
for recovery and renewal.
We have locked them out of the kingdom
and all it takes is the key to get back in.
They have it and we can help them do that.
We can help them reawaken.
We can help them ignite their...
I call it awakened awareness.
Their seat of transcendent awareness
where they can feel direct connection to this pulse of life.
And that can be taught.
I mean, honoring our inner knowing,
connecting as we just did in our visualization
with those who truly have our best interest in mind.
It could be a grandparent who died 20 years ago, right?
It has to do with talking directly to God
or feeling, asking the universe of question
and hearing the answer.
Whether it's through my mind's eye
and my relationship with my higher power?
Whether it's through synchronicity?
Whether it's through the care of the geese
or the duck or the wind?
Being able to see life as a live and guiding.
We're built for that.
That's not a belief it's not a theology.
That doesn't come from a religious leader.
That comes from a scientist saying,
"That we have in our brain a series of circuits
that allow us to see the deep nature of life.
That is in fact buoyant.
That is in fact a consciousness field
through which we are loved, held, guided and never alone."
And so on a very practical level,
if there's a parent listening to this who's dealing with
one of their adolescents who's struggling at the moment.
What are some of the practices or tools that you can relate
that could be conveyed to this young person
to help in that process?
Right, I'll answer very concrete things we can do.
First of all, our young adults
as much as they may be rebelling and pushing us away,
don't want us to even see them listening to us, right?
But remember every word we say
when we speak from our deepest truth.
So if I can tell the story of sitting in the basement
of my dorm in college and wondering if God exists?
But then going that summer to the Gulf of Mexico
and seeing light on the water
and not radically hitting my head against the wall,
ruminating asking if God exist but in that moment feeling.
And then of course, God exists.
Knowing in a deeper, direct way.
Of course, we are held and loved.
But deep awakening in our own paths.
Our children will listen to every word.
I'll give you an example.
When I was a child,
my mother was very profoundly spiritually connected.
Very vocal about her spiritual life.
Prayed out loud, cried at the side of my brother and I.
"Thank you God for these children.
Thank you God for the sunset."
Hallelu...
And just full of life.
And my father was a very quiet, reflective academic
who would read on the back porch and was very cautious
in making any assertions about spiritual life.
But it was my father who the very morning
after his mother died.
I was about nine years old.
I woke up as I always did at 4:00 AM,
went downstairs but I was very surprised that morning
to see my father almost in a ball.
Because my father is 6'5" handsome guy,
basketball player...
In a little ball on the carpet by our living room couch.
And I walked to him I said, "Dad."
And he said, "I had a dream."
This was within 24 hours of his own mother's passing.
"Grandma came to me in my dream.
And where's grandma loved to dress up
and wear pretty clothes and jewelry.
In this dream grandma's in a very everyday gray suit.
It was a suit I saw her wear many times.
And there grandma and I were walking down Grand Avenue."
In Des Moines, Iowa, where my father grew up.
And he said, "You know...
And it was very raw and he certainly was not philosophizing
it was just real as could be.
He said, "You know, I don't know what to make of it
but I guess it means that grandma
had always walked with me as my mother.
She would continue to walk with me as my mother
and the grandma was letting me know that."
Okay, so fast forward I'm decades down the road.
When I think of my father and the depth of our relationship,
I go there.
When I think do our ancestors walk with us, I go there,
I've published reams of articles showing that in India
and in China and Mexico,
there's a deep awareness that ancestors walk with us.
I've published reams of articles showing that
when we know that we're less depressed and addicted.
But I know it's true that our ancestors walk with us
because my father shared his dream.
I had 100% proof of concept, hard data,
in the felt awareness of that very awakened bond.
That was real.
Yeah, that's a beautiful story.
But that's who we are so yes.
And the fact that it came in the form of your dad,
the unlikely kind of spiritual seeker
in comparison to your mom.
Which makes that story all the more kind of poignant, yeah.
And he didn't know what it meant in a theoretical
or theological sense.
It was 100% hard data because it was his genuine experience.
Sure, and yet it requires kind of reckoning.
Like I feel myself even like wanting to dismiss
those stories because there are all
sort of individual experiences
and who knows what's going on in people's brain,
neurochemistry of course.
In the wake of his mother dying
he's gonna be reflecting on that.
And it's not surprising that there would be
some kind of dream and we can just kind of dismiss it
and say, "Oh, that's cute or whatever."
But that's not necessarily real.
Well, and that's why we're depressed
is because we dismiss half our form of human knowing.
It is the part that's buoyant and loving and guiding,
and doesn't leave us alone.
So, you know-
But when it wants you to deal with something
I like the way I always think about it
is the universe is knocking on your door
and it knocks gently like,
Hey, I'm gonna give you a little dream,
maybe look at this.
Or there's gonna be some geese that are gonna fly above you.
Maybe you want to pay attention to that.
And every time that you dismiss it or refuse to look at it
or deny it the next Knocks a little louder,
the next Knocks a little louder,
until suddenly cops are involved in maybe jail
or a mental institution...
Like it just gets increasingly more and more intense
until finally you reach some inflection point
that entails a bunch of pain where you have no choice
but to look at the thing that had you paid attention
to it earlier on would have saved you a lot of consternation
and toil.
I agree with you.
The universe turns the volume up until we hear.
And so where are we trying to get?
We're trying to get as you described so beautifully
into a dialogue with life.
What is life showing me now?
What am I being told here, right?
So we don't step on an inert stage
where we control everything narrowly
what I call achieving awareness.
But we don't control the skies we navigate them, right?
We don't.
We'll get swallowed up in the waves of the ocean
if we think we're gonna control them.
If you get up on top and surf them.
That sense of being in a dynamic relationship
with the guidance spirit in life.
What is life showing me now?
Opens up a path that is one of discovery.
We don't make our way in life.
We discover our way in life.
I have no idea what my life's gonna look like
in 10 years.
But I know when I'm in a state of deep alignment
where I'm listening to life and life is opening doors.
And I know when I'm not.
When I'm not,
it's been both to my peril and everyone around me.
In other words,
there's a relinquishment of the instinct
to enforce yourself well and a reckoning
or a reconciliation with the idea of surrender
and acceptance.
It's more like surfing than it is like
pushing a rock up a mountain.
And this is the great dilemma
for every high achievement person, right?
Like you wanna force a result.
You have an addiction to a certain outcome
and our lives are directed towards increasingly becoming
sort of climbing this mountain towards achievement
or some imagined destination.
When in truth, the greatest miracles in life
and the greatest discoveries
and the experience of deep fulfillment and connection
comes with relinquishing all of that.
Letting go and being in the allowing.
But that requires synchronicity
with that invisible force, right?
You have to do enough inside work so that you are attuned
to those signals and presence enough
and integrated enough with who you are
so that you can be aware and act in accordance
with the signals that you're receiving
And synchronicity is-
And that's yeah, this is a whole synchronicity thing
that you talk about in the book.
That is a knock at the door.
That is one form of life talking to us now is synchronicity.
I love obviously like my first kind of passion
with all of this stuff is addiction and recovery.
And it's always interesting and at times quite frustrating
to have conversations about how to get sober
and what recovery looks like
because I'm basically somebody who got sober in AA
with a very traditional kind of rigor of the 12 steps.
And there's this sense that because a lot of the language
and the vernacular in the big book and all of that
is sort of antiquated and colloquial
that the spiritual piece in the 12 steps
is like the fly in the ointment
or a bug rather than a feature.
And anybody who's kind of gotten sober
or maintained sobriety through this program
understands that spirituality is at the very core
of what this experience is all about.
It's not something that's off to the side
or something that you can kind of choose
to not engage with while you do the rest of it.
And to my mind the work that you've done
and all the science that you've done over the years
really proves this out for me.
Like it validates this methodology.
I am so grateful indeed that this can be brought
to people who are overcoming
and being renewed in recovery.
Yeah, because people will say like,
"(indistinct) I go to AA
but I can't get down with the God thing
or I can't, you know, I'm not a religious (indistinct)."
It's not a religious program it's a spiritual program.
It's a God of your choosing.
Your higher power can be the group.
It can be anything you wanna to be.
But people and this is a big piece I think.
There's a lot of people who have spiritual trauma
or religious trauma because of some experience
when they were younger where
it doesn't necessarily have to be physical abuse,
but some level of bad experience occurred
in their relationship to anything spiritual
that a door comes down and they shut themselves off
from that completely.
That is a story I've heard from hundreds of people
that I was a very spiritual child, I felt connected.
I may be prayed through my faith tradition
or just felt in this deep loving numinous connection.
And then there was a bad messenger.
And the messenger could have been a little bit bad
or a lot bad.
But here she didn't walk the walk, right?
They talked the walk but they didn't walk the walk.
And when the young adult sees hypocrisy
or far worse as even violated by the messenger,
there's a tendency to throw the spiritual baby out
with the bath water, right?
And here's where our confusion
as a culture between religion and spirituality
is really at play.
We have a non conversant society around spirituality
and so much so that I will give a two hour talk
on the science of spirituality
as being distinct from religion.
And then out by the water cooler someone says,
"What's the difference again
between spirituality and religion?"
We're just turn deaf as a culture.
But they're two entirely different things.
Spirituality is in our innate capacity
for transcendent awareness through which we are
in touch with our higher power
or the goodness and spirit and then through one another.
AA is abundant with the presence of God or spirit
and in through one another.
(indistinct) the commitment, the humility,
the openhandedness.
Those relationships are-
It's all in there.
The altruism, the service, the meditation piece,
the availing yourself for others,
the surrender, the acceptance.
It's all baked into it, yeah.
(indistinct) it is a profoundly spiritual community.
And showing up for one another under all circumstances.
being present and transparent, love.
So I don't care whether you just robbed a bank
and went to jail or just got $5 million.
I look at you with love.
And non-judgment.
That is a spiritual relationship.
That's unawakened connection.
That is alive and well in AA and NA.
It is one of the few places
where you can truly find a pan-denominational
or non-denominational spiritual community.
But you also do find spiritual communities
in faith traditions.
You can go to a temple or a mosque (indistinct).
So our culture has really foreclosed spiritual growth
because we're so anxious about religion.
If someone's religious, great.
Find your spiritual life through your faith tradition.
If someone's not religious or uncomfortable with religion,
your spirituality is still alive and well,
and you can still cultivate your spirituality
through other forms of connection and AA.
If only AA could be prevention.
Right.
I mean, I've often thought that anybody
can improve their lives through the process
of undergoing these steps
and being part of some version of that community.
It would be a better world if this was scaled up
and kind of just part of everybody's experience of learning
how to contend with each other and ourselves.
And ourselves and that we are so much more
than what we've done or not done.
What we have or not have, right?
There is a soul on earth in every one of us
and that we can speak to each other
into your deep higher self.
And just the courage to be that honest
and the power of that vulnerability.
And it's so unifying it creates that sense of cohesion
because there's the implicit trust
that comes with that that I think bonds people
and makes you feel connected in a way that nothing else
in my life has been able to provide me with.
And I always feel in the podcast I wanna...
Because I've been at thousands of these meetings,
like I'm always trying to cultivate some version
of what that experience is like for the listener
or the viewer because I just think it's so beautiful
and sacred and special.
AA is an awakening experience.
It has all the components that nourish
and awaken our human brain, everything.
The awakened connection to love
and feel oneness with one another.
It doesn't matter if you're from this hood
and I'm from that hood and you look like that
and I look like this when I'm zipped up by a body suit,
that deep common human heart,
our common seat of experience that is at the center.
It has awakened attention.
What is life showing me now?
I am lying there on the floor,
my husband's walking out for me.
I just lost my money.
What is life showing me now?
It's not showing me that I'm a loser,
life showing me now is that there's a yellow door
that I am not walking through.
(Lisa chuckles)
The witness, the testimony, the transparency,
and the love that-
Yeah, the love like the idea that somebody
who is so broken and has nowhere to turn
can walk into one of those rooms and be embraced
and not judged.
It's just a truly beautiful and unique thing I think that.
And it's real love.
Yeah.
See, that's who we really are.
We can be that way outside of AA.
We can be that way at the bank or at the company
or in our family.
So this is who we really are.
It's hard, it's really hard.
(Lisa laughing)
I wonder, sorry go ahead.
Well, just that I think that what goes on in AA and NA
can be a way of life proactively that we could...
We talked about what could we do in schools?
Couldn't we take those very same principles
and apply them to schools?
That in this classroom we look at each other with love.
It doesn't matter if you just got a C or an A.
If you were just made captain or cut from the team.
This is your brother, this is your sister.
That can be taught.
Yeah, that would be good.
But it's so immediately within range
that is not pie in the sky.
That is not-
Yeah, I know.
It's it seems like a very low bar
and yet at the same time almost impossible.
Well, all we have to do is ratify it.
The Army did it, right?
Two million people, a million enlisted,
a million contractors.
They decided driven from the top, right?
Secretary of the Army, chief, vice chief,
we are going to be a spiritually supportive institution.
Young adults are coming to us broken,
addicted, suicidal, fragile.
We are going to nourish and support their spiritual core.
If the Army can do it, yes.
So can Columbia and Stanford and the University of Arizona.
And so can every single company,
from convenience stores to fast food restaurants.
We can be institutions that support the spiritual core
of young adults.
I wonder in the course of doing all these MRI studies
if there's a sense of some spiritual practices
or traditions being more impactful
or profound in terms of the areas of the brain
that are getting lit up or turned off than others?
Because I suspect there might be somebody listening
or watching this who's like,
"Yeah, I'm not down with the spiritual thing.
I don't really know how to connect with that.
But maybe I can meditate.
Maybe I could do that and just keep any anything
(indistinct) out of it completely is that sufficient?"
Or how do you parse these various traditions
in terms of efficacy?
It's very, very comfortable for most people
to talk about meditating
when it has to do with getting still in present, right?
And I would say, "Okay, so if you're comfortable
doing some form of mindfulness or getting present,
you're now at a threshold.
Do you wanna do mindfulness plus?
Do you want to do meditation plus?"
You're keying in on that achievement (indistinct)
you're like (indistinct)
I wanna get to the next level, yeah.
Plus which is see where you're going
beyond getting present in your attentional work
of getting present.
Which is very, very important stop the racket.
It's the first of the four loops of awakening, right?
Get present.
Where are you going?
Honor your own direct experience.
What are you seeing?
What are the connections that are (indistinct)
on probabilistic to have just happened spuriously by chance?
What might really life be showing you now?
So to become curious keen witnesses
scientists of our own future and look into what's possible.
And then I would say once again,
there is nothing as profoundly strengthening
of our awakened brain as being loving to one another.
The way people are in AA,
the way we can be in families and in schools.
We are far too transactional.
Let's be loving and transformational.
Let's truly show up in a way where
I truly have your best interest in mind.
I mean, truly have your best interest in mind means that
you might get hired, you might get fired.
It's not...
It's the Y-axis not the X-axis.
And you could hire me, you could fire me.
You could train me, you could promote, you can demote me.
That's on the X-axis but the Y-axis all alone
is do you truly have my best interest in mind
as a soul on earth?
As a child of God?
As made of life itself?
Do you see me as a spiritual being?
That's another type of way of living together.
They're not antithetical.
Yeah, and in terms of things that are considered
antithetical they're just the way that we introduce
this whole conversation.
Their science over here, their spirituality over here.
These things sort of live at odds with each other.
But to my mind the more deep your exploration into science
the more mystical and magical it becomes.
And which is why I was kind of delighted
that you went into the quantum physics in the book
and talking about entanglements
and sort of the way that particles
are not location specific and yet tie to each other.
And what we can kind of extrapolate from that
to help cultivate a sense of wonder and awe
and openness to things that we can't necessarily see
with our five senses.
There is no difference between inner and outer.
That if you have a dream or an intuition,
and you wonder what is it gonna be the next turn in my path?
Should I take this job?
Should I marry her?
Should we move across the country?
And then suddenly the guy on the bus
sits down right next to you and said,
"You seem just like the type of person
who'd pack up and move across the country."
That's far too probabilistic to have happened by chance.
For one was an internal question
and one was a so-called external experience,
the guy on the bus.
It is an parsimonious to think that that is random.
It is parsimonious to think that's one thing.
parsimony of course, being the index of good
scientific interpretation.
So there is an emerging science
that shows there's a unit of consciousness field.
And then the consciousness field is not just information.
It has love and intention.
And this is the fabric of reality
that we are designed to see.
Just as we have loops and parts of our brain
they're allowed to see a glass of water.
And on some level I am certain in some way
that this glass of water is here.
When it comes to the capacity to perceive
the unit of guiding nature of life.
We're built for that too.
And when we pay attention to it,
we see that indeed it holds water.
That is time-tested and true
and our lives become much more buoyant and actionable.
And yes, even more outwardly successful
in terms of good traction with reality
when we use our awakened capacities.
When we take that data as real, it bears fruit.
It proves over time.
What's your take on the role of psychedelics
in fostering this?
(indistinct chatter)
I've seen it go different ways for different people.
I think when you look at indigenous traditions
there's a lot of preparation
there's a lot of integration around this.
And I'll share with you.
I've seen people...
Well, let's get it off the question of psychedelics.
I'm gonna talk about a Buddhist nun.
Okay, may I?
Okay, this is a woman who for three years, three months,
three weeks and three days sat in a box
to deepen her awareness, right?
To strengthen her perceptual capacities.
And she indeed went into profoundly
transcendent forms of awareness
and had mystical experiences.
When she came out there was no reintegration process
and she was not guided in how to rejoin the world.
She was...
The community said, "Goodbye, thanks."
And so this woman goes out into the world.
She's now a Buddhist nun.
But her teachers didn't help her reintegrate,
in this case for this woman.
And she felt probably quite accurately
at very deep consciousness level called by the Dalai Lama.
And in her sense of calling she put on her robes,
she packed her bags and she stood out on the lawn
waiting for the Dalai Lama to pull up in a car
and take her to her next assignment.
Okay, it's the same mistake that was made
on the in-patient unit between the world and the world.
It's the wrong level of consciousness
for the matter at hand.
Was she called by the Dalai Lama?
I have every reason to think she was.
Was he going to pull up in a car in her suburban town?
That would be far more unlikely, right?
And not being clear about the difference between the two
was a problem of reintegration.
And that gets...
That appears very much like mental illness.
Yes.
She's in her front yard in a suburban town
waiting for the Dalai Lama to drive up?
Yes.
Okay.
That it appears as mental illness, right?
Yeah.
And it is a confusion about where she is, right?
And what it is to be called the levels of significance
around being called, right?
And that is a confusion that can happen
no matter how we augment our awareness.
Whether it's gradually over time
or whether it's jump-started but in either case,
we need to reintegrate and find a way to take our awakened
understanding and lay that down in a way that's actionable
and aligned with reality.
It can go either way but we need good teachers,
we need good guides.
Yeah, so essentially what you're saying
is it can be a trigger, it can crack a window open
and provide you with some level of awareness
that perhaps you wouldn't have been able to
cultivate on your own.
But it's really less about that than it is about
what you're gonna do in the aftermath of it.
How are you gonna bring that out?
And I feel like a lot of the focus around psychedelics
is on the experience itself
rather than on the integration piece
that you were talking about.
So if someone can come home
and there's their lover of eight years
and I've seen this happen.
You just don't understand the bigger truth.
And relationships are getting cratered.
That's right and you're not as deep.
Every single one of us on earth is subject
to letting narcissism slip in.
Nothing like a little spiritual superiority.
Right, so this relationship isn't working for me anymore,
and I've literally seen divorces over this, right?
It seems to me that integration says,
that if you've reached a deep understanding
and you're further down the spiritual path
than someone else you go back you get your lover
and you bring him or her with you on this path.
You invite them.
I think that's the responsibility
rather than the abandonment
because this no longer works for me.
I'm sorry kids.
Yeah, I'm off to be bigger, right?
So that's very damaging.
That has exactly as we're saying to do with integration.
Yeah, it's interesting.
I have such a dilemma in my own mind.
I mean, it comes up all the time on the podcast
and it's been offered to me.
But as somebody who's been sober for a long time.
I don't know that it's the path for me, you know?
I think I've had my awakening experience
and I know what works for me.
And I don't doubt that there are experiences
perhaps that are unavailable to me
that I could experience by doing that.
But I don't know that it's necessary for me.
Then again, I'm like well, maybe I'm cutting myself off
from reaching a higher plane of awareness.
I don't know.
Solve this problem for me?
From all we've discussed it sounds like
you're very far down an authentic spiritual path
that involves augmented awareness.
And that when that can happen organically
and in dialogue with life that it's...
This is an inspired form of awareness.
We can cultivate readiness for awakened awareness.
But where we actually go and what we see that is,
I would say guided by God or the spirit or consciousness.
And we can create the conditions for augmented experience.
And we can create the conditions and the intentions
for transcendent or mystical journeys.
But where we go that is whether you say God
or the higher power or the nature of life or spirit.
Or there's plenty of words within our reach
indigenous, traditions for where we go.
But we're not mighty mouse.
We don't control where we go.
And I think need a big spoonful of humility in our culture
because the spiritual path is guided
and potentiated by spirit.
(Lisa laughing)
Yeah.
It's confusing.
Well, my point is that spirit...
The force of life will guide us where we need to go
when we say yes, what is life showing me now?
What are you showing me God?
What yellow door might be here?
Okay, this red door it's slammed in my face
and crushed my toes.
So there must be some other door.
Yeah, I think that there's...
Is it not advisable to advise a little bit of caution
in terms of reckoning with your intuition?
And I say this because doesn't it require
like some level of inside work prior to that?
Like you have to be integrated
or have kind of worked through
whatever kind of psychological drama or turmoil
that you've experienced to get to a place of...
I don't know, authenticity,
I don't know what the right word for it is.
But a sense of self-understanding
and self-awareness such that when that intuition arises
or that instinct or that impulse percolates up,
that it can be trusted.
Because if you're out in the world
and addicted to behavior patterns
and you're living your life reactively.
Like you're gonna say, "Well, I have an impulse."
Or "My instinct is telling me that I should go do this."
But you're being impulsed by something
that is not really your higher voice.
It's just some outside stimulus.
And because you haven't done enough work
you can't parse the two.
So when I was working through
some of my most difficult times.
When I was working through depression,
when I was working through really painful moments.
I worked at multiple levels at once.
So I did the basic work around
okay, what patterns have I picked up from my parents?
And what are my patterns in the world?
Important what you might call.
Sort of relational, psychologist called ego-based work.
What are my ways of coping and handling the world?
I worked at that level and I went to the (indistinct)
and I worked in prayer and meditation.
And I worked with a union analyst.
So I think we are needy at all levels of growth
and never is it more of a crisis
than when we're in pain, right?
This is why our suffering is an invitation
is really the invitation of our lifetime
to addressing pain at all levels.
At the relational level learning how to treat one another
at the level of coping the ego level.
What are my patterns?
And at the transcendent level.
Where are you higher power?
Let's see you, higher power.
And let's see you through one another.
All these people showing up.
Your trail angels is what I call them in Awakened Brain.
So I think we need everything all hands on deck.
And that's why whether someone...
If someone's deeply depressed,
whether or not we choose to take medication,
we still need to do the spiritual work.
It's not enough to feel better.
Because it's a formative work.
It is the foundation for the next round in our lives.
And when it comes to young adults
whether or not they need medication,
whether or not they take medication,
they need to do the work of awakening
because that is the foundation for the rest...
They're building on the foundation.
Their values, their direction,
their capacity to be in deep dynamic relationship
with the spirit and then through life.
They're building that through their suffering.
So of course we wanna make pain go away,
but at the same time,
let's not miss the opportunity of their lifetime
to strengthen their spiritual core.
I think you said that of all people
that present with depression
or maybe it was just young people
that actually only 1/3 of those
are our patients who qualify for some kind of medical
or pharmaceutical intervention
with the difference between clinical depression
and the depression that ensues
because of some kind of life event that's more
to the common experience of (indistinct)-
Why doesn't Jason loved me, right?
That is a developmental depression.
And developmental depression
as our spiritual capacity boots up.
It can often feel in this enlarged hunger for transcendence,
this acute desire for elimination and connection
and nagging for truth.
It can feel like a half empty glass of spirituality.
And the other the empty piece is developmental depression.
It's and we.
And I hear from young adults,
it's when I don't allow myself to ask these questions
that the depression sharpens that it feels more acute.
We have to do this work of formation.
We have no choice but to go on a spiritual quest.
Every tradition has known it.
When we foreclosed the quest,
what we get is the big donut sized hole in the heart.
We get the lack of formation,
the lack of of the knowing heart, the perceiving heart,
that is a direct connection to God or the higher power.
The perceptual organ through which we say,
"Ah, red door slammed.
Where's the yellow door.
Ah, he left me, she left me but look who just showed up?"
This ability to see that life is dynamic
and full of surprises and we don't make those surprises
and we don't make that dynamism but we can embrace
this give and take, this dialogue with life.
That is quest.
I think that's beautifully put.
And I would say a nice place to end it.
But I think there's one more thing
that I wanna explore which is helping people
figure out a path forward.
If somebody who's listening to this or watching it
and they have difficulty or they struggle with the idea
of connecting with something quote, unquote, "spiritual"
or they have kind of just an allergy to the vernacular
or the terminology itself.
Like what are some means by which a person
can begin to kind of connect with that sensibility
that could kind of catalyze them along their path?
The knowing of the heart is real.
That's hard data.
So honoring and respecting the hunch,
the little whisper and the tiny,
tiny little sapling of have a hunch honor that.
Get it love, get it of attention.
When you pay attention to your flashes of awareness,
when you catch a synchronicity out of the corner of your eye
and say, "I think I saw something."
Honor that.
Treat your perception as real.
And when you do it grows very, very quickly.
Tenfold, a hundredfold.
Listen to yourself and honor your inner knowing
as hard data.
And the second thing is I invite you to draw
a road of your life.
And this is in The Awakened Brain.
And on the road of your life,
I invite you to put a door that slammed in your face.
Put your red door where A plus B plus C,
it was all lined up and you wanted that so bad
and it was yours and the door was stuck or the door slammed.
And only because it slammed you found the yellow door.
And I invite you to draw that yellow door
on your road of life.
And because you've found that yellow door
you need to shift direction
and take that pen or pencil and show the curve
if not the hairpin turn, (indistinct) in your road of life
to go through that yellow door.
What was on the other side?
What was there that was magnificent
that was much more vast than you ever envisioned?
Now on that road of life where the red door slammed
and you did the hairpin turn
and went through the yellow turn.
Did anyone show up at that time?
I mean, it could have been someone
that you've lived with for 30 years,
or it could have been someone you met right there
at the junction.
But can you draw them in there?
And what did they say to you about the yellow door?
And what did they say to you about the red door?
That person at the junction that changed your life
might they be a trail angel.
And as you step back could you populate your road of life
with not just one or two red doors and yellow doors,
one or two trail angels but have there not been dozens,
if not hundreds of trail angels and red doors
and yellow doors.
And actually as you step way back
where you in someone else's road of life?
How important you are and how important we are
in this symphony that we can all see
when we look through our awakened eyes.
That's so beautifully put and really powerful.
I think that this process is enhanced with
the more present and aware you are,
the more red and yellow doors you see in your life, right?
Like if you're just stumbling through life,
you're not aware of when doors are opening or shutting
but the more you're kind of anchored in the moment
and really paying attention to what's going on around you.
I think we're all visited with these things on the regular.
And when we use our awakened awareness to see yellow doors
and red doors and through them
and say, thank you to our trail angels
and inhabit that role for one another.
Like recognizing it?
Like expands it.
Expands it exponentially.
Life is buoyant.
Life is loving and it is anything but depressing.
(Rich laughing)
Good because we don't need any more depression, Lisa.
That's right.
Depression is about not getting what we want,
not being who we want.
But from an awakened perspective life is full.
We've just got to figure out where that yellow door is.
It's different for everybody.
Yeah.
Well, it's so nice talking to you.
It's great talking to you.
Yeah, that was great.
How do you feel?
Amazing.
Good.
Wonderful talking to you.
I feel good that was very uplifting.
The book is The Awakened Brain.
You can get it everywhere.
Also The Spiritual Child your first book
which I have not read yet.
But I'm gonna read that next.
So thank you, I love this book.
I am at your service.
Anything I can do to help get your message out.
And if people wanna connect with you?
What are you up to next?
Or where should they go?
I know you've got your website and all that stuff.
Absolutely, I'd love people to visit my website.
It's lisamillerphd.com.
The Awakened Brain.
And we also have the Spirituality Mind Body Institute
at Columbia University
and they're welcome to connect with us there.
Yeah, can we just drop in?
You are always welcome.
You may wanna drop in
I wanna come to a class.
Are you teaching this fall?
I would love you to come to a class.
I'm on sabbatical, my first in 16 years.
I will be there in the spring.
All right, I'm coming to a class.
I look forward to that.
All right, excellent.
We'll put you to work.
You're gonna have to talk and lecture.
(Rich laughing)
And I'm talking.
I wanna sit in the back and watch the cockroaches.
That's what I'm gonna do.
Unfortunately, you will be invited to the front.
(Lisa laughing)
Oh, no.
Okay, all right.
And we look forward to it.
Thanks.
Thank you, Lisa.
Peace, peace.
(orchestral music)